they ask aoc i don't know if you saw
that when they asked aoc and she didn't
want to answer the questions like hey so
what do you think about uh uh tyler do
you have that story here as a wonderful
morning again yeah hey do you think if
biden ran again or she equivocated yeah
she's like well listen now the only
thing you said page number four bottom
of four bottom of four okay so you know
hey if biden ran would you support biden
and she's like uh uh uh well
you know what we first need to do is uh
ocasio-cortez won't commit to back in
biden in 2024 we'll cross that bridge
when we get to it cnn i think if the
president has a vision then that's
something certainly we're willing to
entertain and examine when the time
comes a democrat who wields significant
amount of influence over the party's
progressive wing told cnn dana bash on
state union when asked if she plans to
support biden in the 2024 election and
that's not a yes i said to which the
congresswoman replied we should endorse
when we get to it but i believe that the
president's been doing a very good job
so far and you know
should he run again i think that i you
know i think we'll take a look at it but
right now we need to focus on winning
the majority instead of presidential
election so in other words that's a
professional way of avoiding the
answering to questions so that that is
what happens when you're in that
business for a while but
people on both sides are sitting there
saying this guy is the least popular
president we've ever had with polls so
you know if you're going to use polls
when you're winning you also ought to
use polls when you're losing and it's
not in a good situation so i think the
middle's running america right now and
if there is a party that's recruiting
the most people today if there is a
party that's recruiting to most people
today i think it's the middle i don't
think it's the left i don't think it's
the right i think it's the middle can i
bring in some more psychology sure
so i feel like i should pay you for this
i'm getting a whole full-on mental
breakdown right here so i want you to
imagine this as the cork of a wine
bottle okay i i've i've explained this
previously but it's worth repeating so
there's an expression in arabic arabic
is my mother tongue so there's an
expression in arabic that basically says
getting drunk simply by smelling the
cork of the wine bottle which basically
refers to when someone doesn't is so
weak of in his constituency that they
don't need to actually drink the wine to
get drunk they simply whiff it and
they're already drunk now how do we
apply this to psychological processes
so look now i'm going to drink from the
obama cork right
oh my god he is so
tall and lanky and he has a mellifluous
voice
and he speaks with the cadence of a
baptist minister now every single
syllable that he utters is pure empty
vacuous [ __ ] but my god
i'm getting drunk by the obama cork
right on the other hand i'm gonna now
smell the cork of trump
he's disgusting he's an ogre right
he he he speaks like a brash
brawler from the bronx right in both of
those cases when i got drunk i never
said anything of substance i didn't say
i like obama because of his fiscal
policy i hate trump because of his
immigration policy what i'm using are
peripheral cues meaning cues that don't
really matter to to to base my decision
on right one is
presidential looking and acting the
other one is brash and an ogre
that's the problem with uh the
psychology of voters and that is that
instead of activating their cognitive
system here are the seven reasons the
substantive reasons why i love biden or
trump most of the populist doesn't do
that they base peripheral cues and
that's why we end up with people voting
for biden even though on every single
position they might prefer trump i know
a lot of my colleagues who when i when i
challenged them on why did you vote for
trudeau or right they could never
enunciate the position he looked young
he looked youthful he looked uh he was
handsome he had a young family [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] right none of these
reasons should be valid reasons for why
you should vote for him but yet that's
why we what happens we get intoxicated
by smelling the core so but you're
giving the personality versus policy
debate exactly right but a lot of people
do vote based on personality
exactly
so it's not based on policy you're
saying right right but isn't that sad
right i mean i don't think a lot of
people are smart enough to to break down
policy by policy and that's not a knock
on the american voter i think most
people just vote with their pocketbook
you know as james carville said we
brought up yesterday it's the economy
stupid clearly people are not happy with
the economy right now
but a lot of times people will just look
on screen and just say yeah i like that
guy exactly or no i don't like the way
they talk
i'm into it or i'm not into that what's
more important that or winning the
middle
is it that or winning the middle because
i think the average voter does that
but the middle voter is sitting there
the independent voter the guys in the
middle the independent the libertarian
those guys are sitting there saying
they have
okay so the pendulum of being able to
reason okay
whoever can reason the most
leads the country okay the complainers
are the complainers are the loudest so
they seem to be the biggest party
the and and the complainers tend to
recruit a lot of the people that are
kind of like oh that's what oh my gosh
so that's what's going on okay so the
complainers recruit the naive
but the complainers cannot recruit the
reasonable people that know how to
reason the people that are in the middle
that are able to reason and they
eventually have enough of a voice you
sit there and you say
huh
okay this guy makes sense yeah i agree
with them you know what yeah that's what
i'm gonna vote for rogan okay again goes
back to bill maher the conversation we
had briefly yesterday i think the
currency again this you're gonna hear me
saying this a lot
i think the currency of reasoning
is becoming very valuable today not
sensationalism
not crying complaining all of that stuff
crying complaining has been a very hot
commodity the last 10 20 years
especially the last two three four five
years right but you're gonna see the
ability to reason become valuable again
this sounds weird for where people
should say well this should this should
have been valuable for a long time no
when social media came out complainers
got a hot mic
and complainers got a chance to go out
there and blow up yeah and complainers
became celebrities aoc is a queen of
complainers and look what happened to
her that was a hot commodity right she
threw a lot of complaining she got a lot
of eyeballs and she got people to say
yeah that's exactly right that's and
then people are like uh you just cost
new york city 25 000 jobs at 150
thousand dollar year salary
amazon and amazon went elsewhere so your
complaining just cost us 25 000 good
jobs yes but if amazon would have came
your rent would have gone up of course
do you want those 150 000 out of your
jobs no they should go elsewhere other
cities are like dude amazon we will
gladly take you buddy they had a bidding
bring those jobs to us we'll take it so
so it's becoming sexy again to reason
those who can reason people are finding
it very very attractive and that's
generally the people in the middle well
and i i think if if i can speak about
you know the platform that guys like
jordan and i have been able to build i
mean i could have never imagined that 10
15 years ago i could ever have the type
of platform that would have been
reserved for you know rock stars and
actors and so on right so i think to
your point i think there is in the
middle the the silent majority are
starving for commonsensical people who
come and actually say exactly what
they're thinking this is why by the way
notwithstanding what you're talking
about the academy i i agree with having
those programs if we can just instill
the courage in the silent majority to
speak out already the battle will be won
this is why i talk about activate your
inner honey badger right because i
receive a million emails every week from
people who say i'm on your side and
they're corrections officers and their
truck drivers and their fancy professors
but for whatever reason they have this
impediment whereby they're scared to
speak their mind
they actually overestimate the risk i
understand that you could be canceled
you could
estimate the risk not underestimate so
they think
it's going to be worse than it's
actually going to be exactly so for
example the the the administrators at
the university who are beholden to the
fl the few loud activists why are you
always acquiescing to them like
why is it that you are always catering
your policies to the 10 people who are
the most committed or the corporations
right exactly the corporations do the
same thing they think as though you know
disney is going to completely you know
fall apart if we don't have ultra work
stuff so you overestimate the risks from
the walk when in reality look i'm still
standing
i don't want to jinx it but i'm
apparently i'm uncancelable i i truly am
like the teflon king well i don't think
it's because there's a magic recipe it's
simply because i don't care i'm not so
afraid of it now you might come along
and say oh but that's because you're
tenured therefore you're not afraid to
lose your job but listen when i get a
million death threats where i have to
walk in on campus with security
tenure didn't protect me there right so
when i almost got an anxiety attack
because i don't know who's gonna come at
me we had to file a police report with
the montreal police at my university
because of the number of death threats
but i walk around like a honey badger
i'm not trying to tooth my horn but look
it's better to live five minutes with
integrity than 500 years as a coward
right and so a lot of people who's that
william wallace
is that true i don't know that sounds
like i just came up with it from top of
my head
i guess many people have had similar but
the honey badger takes what he wants
honey badger does i mean for those of
you who don't know who are listening to
the show the honey badger has been
ranked as the fiercest animal in the
world it's the size of a small dog and
yet it could withstand the attack of six
adult lines the reason why i say six is
because you could probably go on on
youtube now and see the the
videos right where there are literally
six adult lions that are intimidated by
this one honey badger why because it's
fierce so be ideologically fierce if
you've got a position that you think is
worthwhile you know standing on don't
cower away don't be a little punk there
you go there you go yeah this guy's a
badass so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]